Simpsons okay may have a problem with
this one everyone my name is Michael
Franzese I'm a former capo in the
Colombo crime family one of the five New
York Mafia families and spent it over 20
years in that life and I'm here today to
review some iconic scenes from various
Slavia movies TV shows so on and so
forth but I think you'll find it very
interesting
you think I'm skimming off the top make
your unlucky a Michael Corleone very
famous scene again eases a bad name for
Italians nobody wants to be called that
when you're Italian
having said that to a guy in Michael
Corleone's position wouldn't worry he
would have got hurt right there on the
spot salting him left and right I mean
you just don't do that another thing in
this scene again Duvall played this role
brilliantly but it was fictional in the
Godfather because the kansui area is a
real position you got to take the earth
and become a made member in order to be
consul years
well Robert Duvall on this he wasn't
even Italian and you can't become a made
guy
unless you're Italian Mike you don't
talk to a man like Moe green like that
there's no way that Fredo would have
told Michael in real life hey do you
realize who you're talking to when his
brother is the mob boss
I thought the Godfather was the greatest
mob movie ever I really do I still feel
that way but that scene was very
unrealistic no doubt if I had to rate
that scene you're realism on a scale of
1 to 5 that would be a while it might
even be a zero I think in all fairness I
should explain to you exactly what it is
that I do
for instance tomorrow morning I'll get
up nice and early take a walk down over
to the bank and walk in and see and if
you don't have my money for me I'll
crack your head wide open I gotta tell
you I've seen and heard been around
people that have done that you know what
it surprised me here is that Pesci
didn't hit him right on the spot just
smack him right in the mouth smack him
around a little bit but he controlled
himself pretty well you people out of
money and get away with it
hey fat Irish pretty boy money to sleep
you go get my money or I'll put your
brain to sleep joe pesci without a doubt
is the most realistic the greatest actor
in a mob role ever he just lights it up
I knew guys like him so he's real he
portrays a mob guy better than any mob
guy that I knew I can tell you this I
guarantee that it's not scripted in
every way the way he says it you know he
was part of that life will be grew up in
it in a way and he's got it down pat on
a scale of 1 to 5 I give this a 5
extremely realistic the only thing that
was missing is he probably would have
hit him right on his spot at least
smacked him wants it twice
Simpsons ok may have a problem with this
I never saw the senses in my life even
got the mob in the Simpson show received
his weekly payment for keeping
McDonald's and Burger King out of town
Artie's oh my gosh my butt of my puppet
I was pretty realistic you're not
getting away with paying $5 when you owe
more I'll tell you that much on a scale
of one to five I rate this a five
Simpsons got it you got a debt on the
street you don't get away with it you
either run away or you never get away
from the juice money and you're
collecting big on it every week you're
gonna have to pay it all I never knew
that the mob was involved even with the
Simpsons it's pretty cool you definitely
don't want a silencer you want to make a
lot of noise to make the witnesses run
away sorry ain't gonna be looking at you
you know my view of the Irishman in
general is that well acted of course I
got all the brilliant actors in there
but it was unrealistic the movie well I
shouldn't say that it was really untrue
you know Scorsese always makes great mob
movies so the movie itself was brilliant
you know I'll be honest with you back in
the day we didn't look for using a
silencer for a certain reason we didn't
want to make noise so people would run
away never heard of anything like that
I mean you pick your weapon and you you
that's it the noise of 45 makes because
that makes too much noise and a patrol
car can hear it a few blocks away at
least okay
the difference in noise between a 45 and
a lighter caliber that's silly I mean I
don't know why he would even say
something like that you're gonna make
noise and make noise and back in the day
it was either a 32 or a shotgun those
are the two weapons that we use most of
the time you never you never got a lot
of advance notice all you knew was
you're part of it I will say now what he
is saying is true when you have a hit
squad like that you try not to give too
much information to the people that are
involved in it really just the main guy
knows everything the other guys are just
coming along and you do that for
security purposes you don't want the
people with you you know knowing too
much just in case they did become an
informant at some point in time so this
is realistic this is a bit personal to
me not that I had anything to do with
the shooting I didn't but this was my
time my family and I was very well aware
of what was going on at that time
because the family was on the brink of
war this is back when Joey Gallo had
planned the assassination of Joe Colombo
at the italian-american civil rights
League they happened to be there that
day and I was 10 steps away from Joe
Colombo when he got shot so I knew what
happened then I knew what happened in
the aftermath I know for a fact that
Frank's your hand was not one of the
shooters for Joey Gallo in that regard
this was untrue
you know the depiction of the scene it
was pretty good because that's the way
it happened shooter went in there and
they did start shooting at him when his
family was president which is something
that's not normally done but this was a
strong message to Joey Gallo that what
he did was just wrong
I mean you shoot a a mob boss in front
of 50,000 people his family and
everybody else so he paid the price so
the scene itself was pretty accurate but
again sheer him was not the killer so on
a scale of one to five I would give this
probably a to know when you think of
prison you get pictures in your mind of
all those old movies with bows and bows
of guys behind bars but it wasn't like
that for wiseguys I've been asked this a
million times
I gotta clear this up right away I spent
eight years in prison I was arrested I
think 17 or 18 times in my life so I've
been in jails all over the country my
dad did 40 years in prison so basically
I've been either in prison or visiting
prisons my entire life this scene is
total nonsense
I mean look Italian guys we had a little
better at times in prison because we had
guys in the kitchen so we'd eat a little
better we never had this kind of stuff
coming in contraband every once in a
while maybe we got a little you know
treat coming into the prison but nothing
like this I mean this isn't even a jail
I don't even know where they are looks
like they're still in somebody's house
so totally unrealistic I wish it was
like that but it was you know as far as
realism on this I have to give it a zero
because there's no way that anything
like this ever took place but I'll tell
you something I was proud to be Johnny
Sopranos kid well he beat the [ __ ] out
of that guy I went to the class I told
him how tough my father was do you think
that's how your son feels about you yeah
probably
and I'm glad I'm glad if he's proud of
me but that's the bind I'm in because I
don't want him to be like me I think the
dialogue is right on here I'm thinking
of myself talking about you know my
father and how I'd want my son to think
about me throughout my time in that life
I know a lot of guys that would not want
their children to follow them in that
life most of the guys wanted their sons
to be educated I think it's pretty
realistic as far as the dialogue now who
he's saying it to and in the you know
the context of this scene that's
unrealistic if a mob boss was ever
visiting a psychiatrist he'd be in the
trunk of his car by the end of the week
along with his psychiatrist because it
would be the same as if he was talking
to a cop well he became an informant so
that part of The Sopranos totally
unrealistic how come I'm not making pots
in Peru you're born today you are what
you are yeah obviously I disagree with
that I know you're not born into well
you're born into it but it's not a
genetic deal where you have to follow in
your father's footsteps so it's really
just the way circumstances turn out
that's how it was in my life so I want
to scale a 1 to 5 the overall scene I'd
have to rate as zero because you'd never
see a mob boss talking to a psychiatry
if he did he'd be killed no doubt about
it but as far as what Tony said I would
rate that as a five but just be careful
I just caution you when you watch this
don't take everything as being factual
and the truth take a lot of this with a
grain of salt a lot of things are
fictional but there's always some
semblance of truth in many of them that
I've seen just enjoy the movies enjoy
the television series dude that's what
they're there for entertaining
[Music]